do you consider mainstream journalism
left because my view is more of a
corporatist
analysis which is that yeah you you know
you've got MSNBC which editorially
editorially is left or Center left
Democratic and Fox News has its view and
then you've got you know the blaze and
Breitbart and whatever but I time it and
again and end up coming to the
conclusion that really there is a profit
motive and sort of establishment as the
sense makers priority more than being
left right or center absent you know
some examples of smaller media outlets
I'm guessing maybe you see it
differently well I I think mostly if
places like the New York Times right so
just what what would be said about Trump
in the New York Times and how how
accurate will it be right and and the
pro the problem is that this is just a
symmetrical warfare every error in the
New York Times matters errors on Fox
News don't matter as errors cut to to
their to their bases and and today or
end to the even to the to the really to
anyone it's like we we you and I expect
Fox News to get it wrong a lot
yes and it's and that's just that's
built into our understanding of what
that platform is it's not real
journalism I mean occasionally it will
produce factual reporting no doubt but
it is a it's a platform of advocacy
pretending to be journalism much of the
time and you know Trump's errors and
lies as we've observed don't matter tip
to his base and in many cases they're
not even I mean they're they're they're
truly features they're not even bugs
that they're you know overlooking
they're just this is part of the fun
just winding up the Lib tardes with
lives but when that when the New York
Times gets it wrong it matters to you
know a supporter and subscribe and
subscribe or like myself and it also
matters it's also used against us by the
right and by by Trump supporters too
I mean it really is a very long armed
lever that gets pulled because you know
just one error gets seems to justify
allegations of fake news and you know
trumped arrangement syndrome and let me
see you got this wrong basically
everything's wrong right
and then then we're just on some you
know greased ramp des sliding down to
pizza gate and you know they're just
there's no such thing as facts anymore
and it's a very disorienting asymmetry
but it's a powerful one